do you feel you've always seemed to me
like kind of a bit to be like a lone
wolf kind of do you feel that I think
that in I don't feel that in life I feel
like if anything I it's an embarrassment
of riches with how many great mentors
and friends that I have in in and out of
comedy but when you're 28 years old and
you hit the stratosphere nobody can talk
to you about that nobody understands it
and perception takes over because then
people start to believe that maybe
you're not accessible and in who is
accessible to you you don't find out two
years later bullshitters people want to
make a little scratch right people that
see something to gain ground rolls
[ __ ] it's like most Eisley cantina
from Star Wars laughs all the scum and
villainy wants to seek you out because
they wanted they want a piece of a
sparkle man yeah everybody wants some of
the sparkle you see somebody a sparkle
it's like oh [ __ ] I want to I want to
glimmer with that person but now what
happens like but D it's always seem like
you do you have this thing reached like
you you have to I have to do this myself
because it always seems like you are
this different kind of like you're like
Pluto kind of a little bit not that
you're out pushed to the outside yeah
but that you choose to kind of be in
this you know like yeah you don't know
if I'm a planet or a ball of ice yeah
I'm a thing or just like a rumor that
science made up you know yes yeah you
don't really know this guy a planet is
this guy a ball of ice I like you see
you seem like that you seem so just a
regular comedian coming up you know it's
like who is just like everybody else
seems a little bit more accessible a
little bit more you feel bad I don't
feel that with a lot of comedians
yeah maybe and that could is but your
graduation question your graduating
class in my in my graduating class I
wouldn't feel that way about the comics
I came up with him around but I think it
maybe it's generational when I met
people ahead of me I was intimidated to
go up and talk to them you know what I
did I did the same thing people kind of
put on me which is they don't want to
talk
me why would that person care about me
why would I'd see David Spade or Chris
Rock when I was young in New York why
would they care about talking to me so
what did I do I projected they're
probably too cool for school yeah until
finally you're at the comic table with
somebody or we're John like this and
you're like oh [ __ ] no that's it's not
that crazy
yeah no it's definitely I don't feel
like the warden of the north like some
Game of Thrones thing where I'm I'm
Pluto or something on the far outside I
do like that that's part of the
interpretation of what I am because it's
a whole hell of a lot more interesting
to be somebody who where people want to
put their hand on their chin and go
let's go then somebody was like yeah
yeah yeah we got it we got it I never
wanted to be that I thought I was that I
actually thought I was like yo yo we get
it you move around a lot on stage and
trying to write some stuff we get it and
dismissed
but if anything the polarizing was like
oh good yeah I'm not milquetoast I'm not
[ __ ] boring right I'm interesting I'm
almost like a little bit of a good guy
bad guy you don't know how I'm Lance
what I feel like with you it seemed like
the antihero yeah I mean you know what
it was fun it's been fun it has that
been a goal it seems like because you I
feel like you you definitely seem like
obviously super aware especially
comedians or hyper aware yes who we are
and what's going on I think anyway a lot
of in super sensitive and super
sensitive yeah which is one of the
reasons you have to be hyper aware
because you have to know or those things
kind of go together because it's like
you're so aware that it makes you overly
sensitive because you're taking in so
much that there's so many ways that you
could feel that we could feel offended
yeah easily so we're so you know aware
and then so sensitive at the same time
yeah I think that we're a lot of comics
I think what we do is we you know we
ruminate and we are we're seeing 10
different incarnations of what could be
and what does that do that that that
then makes you start preparing for what
if a happens what if B happens we exert
a lot of energy even in our stunts dude
it is exhausting yeah and hyper where
yes Austin having to constantly like
protect yourself from like seven
different ways of feeling uncomfortable
right you know you ever hear those
stories about Jim Carrey early on in his
career when he would he had this
and did you ever work with him no I
never had the opportunity to work with
him but I've I've worked with people
that have collaborated with him and I I
usually don't just on hearsay
I need like a few different people to
validate and I started hearing from a
few different folks that like back in
the day when he would go to a party if
he thought people were gonna [ __ ] with
him doing what we're doing thinking up
so and so is gonna be there what if she
says this what if he says that that he
would sit and pre-plan some stuff to you
know roast you or hazed you right so you
couldn't hurt him some eight-mile [ __ ]
man he had like it already on tap he'd
practice you know imagine the energy
that that took because what if you had
eleven people yeah your [ __ ] neck
right he yeah he that's the neck you
wore yeah I could see him yeah he would
go he would go deep cuts yeah on that
[ __ ] and and I understand a little bit
of that I think that I think that the
you know if you're thinking about a
career in comedy what you got to realize
is it's it's an amazing community it's a
brotherhood I mean that guys and girls
but it's also really cutthroat and it's
also sometimes it's very participatory
and sometimes it's very isolating you
know and you got to know what you need
to be at what point right and that's
hard to know and I had to learn the hard
way which was pretty much on my own but
then meeting mentors along the years
that were the knowledge that they passed
on to me helped me to figure out what a
career really is and there's gonna be a
cresting you're gonna dip and it's gonna
come up and then it did there's so many
more elements than just what we do on
stage right you know when you so when
your career like blew up you know cuz I
mean you had what I mean and I've talked
about this even in discussions about you
when you weren't around that you were
like kind of the Steve Martin of our
time in the way that well some of you
know that somebody no one has that I
mean that's such a rare thing that
somebody has you know has the Hat
trajectory yeah yeah it's just a rare
thing it happens to someone you know and
it happened to
you and not saying that your you know
obviously you did the work but what
happens like with your ego in that part
that's something we always talk about it
because that one of my scariest things
to me is my own ego right because it's
such a it's me and I know that I'm
crafty and then I'm cunning yeah and so
I know that my ego is that as well right
like what happened like with the like
did you find for yourself what I found
was maybe a little different because I
had grown up so as an introvert I had
grown up with a lot of fear I grew up as
a self-loathing
manok I was in an environment of there
was alcoholism in my family yeah there's
a heaviness and I felt like I grew up
fast so the years that I spent doing
stand-up leading up to what would
seemingly be an overnight sensation 15
years later the ego stuff really wasn't
like a bravado or some kind of cockiness
it was really more of oh I'm finally
starting to feel like I can love myself
because I obtained something in life
where I didn't really know what I would
get to you know I pipe dreamed a lot of
stuff Steve Martin and dice and seeing
these guys definitely always have those
in your head especially if you're in the
business and you're seeing other people
have those things yeah and so I think
that too if I'm if I'm understanding
correctly it's like to me like ego was
like I'd be at the cellar when I was
still new and Chris Rock would come in
he bumped me he bump anybody and that
was that was like that was part of it
that was kind of like a rite of passage
as a comedian like okay some big star
bigger stars gonna come in and so when I
made it I was like oh I can do that too
you know I can walk into the Laugh
Factory which is primarily where I would
just go and feel like I can do what I
want this is I've arrived so that was
something I needed to get through the
rotating door about to realize like no
they're still actually like it's still
procedural and you can still have
respect for your peers and there's a way
to do that that's more appropriate than
just a barnstorming a club and then
right don't you know so I got my knocks
and
some lesson learned earlier yeah yeah
and only because certain names and some
ID names you know would reach out and be
I can't do that man you know you don't
want you don't want to do that you want
to try to play it like this or and so I
you know I learned as I went and now I
try to kind of what we're doing here
pass on to whoever the next girl or guy
is coming up to say like you know when
people say stay humble that's no
[ __ ] you know really try to you know
keep yourself as modest and you know
it's nice to be self affirming but you
got a you got a you got to be able to
like if you're gonna get a a huge level
of of power in in any industry really
like how you manage that in how it it
reverberates off you to others that
impacts you years later when that person
says hey thanks for being cool to me
yeah you know thanks for being I
remember one time like Tosh he got
really mad at me
we were I didn't never was really close
to him and we were in the Laugh Factory
Lobby once and I usually talk out of
school but like this is one of those
stories that and I think I had put my
hand out to him and he was like no man
no I don't need you in my life he said
something that was really kind of harsh
and I was like Daniel well I'm just you
know congrats on the success and all
that and he he he was not interested in
having that conversation because I had
not been I had not been cordial to him
coming up I probably didn't take the
time on many nights at the factory to to
hobnob or just yeah just to I had not
realized that the level of influence
that I had that that younger comedians
at that moment not now but at that
moment like that would hurt them if I
were to walk by and not acknowledge them
but I wasn't doing it to hurt anybody I
was just still an introvert in many ways
right you know it's it's a man it's a
[ __ ] it's perplexing in a paradox
sometimes even you know for me we had a
very deep conversation off pod and you
know we're we're we're complex you know
we're complex means you and I have never
been like close but we just seen each
other at clubs too
a few times and and yeah and then I came
up to your house and and we hung out
that time yeah it was definitely
interesting cuz I didn't know yeah it's
like I feel like other comedians are you
kind of get a vibe from and you kind of
get an understanding of and you just
kind of seem like that like that rare
element that's kind of like well what's
going on with this guy like this guy
this guy's out this guy's kind of seems
like a lone wolf to me yeah I guess that
in terms of how I came up in comedy
that's a fair assessment because I
wasn't in a pack that was all doing
arenas and and Billboard charts and
top-selling platinum albums I I was
alone yeah I was really alone there
wasn't another person dice was 25 years
ahead of me having done Madison Square
Garden 1990 and I bumped him to emit
Mulberry Street pizza when I was like it
was like oh 506 and everything I was by
myself just having a slice just [ __ ]
sitting there you know napkins on my
face he sat right in front of me and I
got to you know have this conversation
with an icon somebody I looked up to and
and I felt like finally I was talking
with somebody who really understood what
I was talking about the hardships that
within the loneliness you know there
there was some loneliness I was like I
got here because I wanted to be in the
community and share but I didn't know I
was gonna seemingly skyrocket to where
people felt like a disappointment I
wanted to I thought that was good for
the business of all comedy right you
know because in the 90s comedy albums
were dead everybody was telling me
comedy was kind of like you know after
the boom of the 80s everybody told me
they're like comedy isn't like you know
it was oversaturated Comedy Central
wasn't putting on people that were
really seasoned and Yeti and so there
was a period of time where comedy was a
little bit bottom of the totem pole and
I felt like hey I'm I think I'm helping
to shed light on a new generation of
comedy fans yeah
so I would sigh perspective very
different about what people felt of me
to what I was hoping that I was
emulating out there for others you know
yeah and jealousy probably was huge I
mean I can only imagine that like Jeff
cuz everybody was a little bit jealous
of Dane Cook I think you know I think
that
what happened was a lot of comics would
say to me man I'm so sick of DJs and
people that are interviewing me for my
show I'm trying to build saying
literally saying why don't you do a Dane
does yeah why aren't you and it was
frustrating
why heard you say on stage one time this
one of the most interesting things I've
ever heard someone say on stage you said
you haven't going to therapy a lot
recently and it's interesting that I'll
sit down i sat down in the therapists
office for the first time and they're
like Oh Dane Cook I've heard a lot I've
heard your name a lot of here from other
comedians yeah and that was like such an
interesting I just remember hearing that
man and that was such an interesting
thing yeah it was it was weird you know
I remember that moment and being like
because he had worked with lot of
comedians I was recommended by it right
yeah yeah the comedy community like you
should talk to him because he he gets it
he knows the world of comedy his opening
line literally was your name comes up a
lot in here man yeah it's like the
vulnerability in that moment of being
like been wanting to know what are they
source of course that would be so
bizarre because then it's like there's
so much of you going on outside of you
right lots of you in such a conversation
of you outside of you right and it
wasn't till sometime that certain comics
had you know come to me and said one
comedian she was she was so I don't want
to name-drop her if she wants to come
forward and say Bobby Whitney Cummings
but it was not winning but I love
Whitney but this comedian came to me and
just said you know I it took me a while
I was one of the people that bashed you
I misjudged you I and she's like a lot
of that was my own feeling of not
getting to you know what I was hoping
the fear you know it's really like
everything comes back to love and fear
man what drives us oh yeah and what we
you know what we want to hold on to and
and what we want to pass up on good
evening good afternoon and other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watches wall
ah